one of the most
boring news events that we have to
endure every 17 years
is the emergence of the cicadas when
they crawl out of their underground
layer to wreak havoc across the land all
at the behest of
the evil wizard soremon i may be
confusing them with orcs from lord of
the rings come to think of it but in any
case
the whole thing always ends up being a
dud the cicadas are hyped up for years
and then they come out
they fly around for a little bit and
they die the only thing that makes this
year's cicada batch a little bit more
interesting is that this time
there are a bunch of freaks out there in
the media trying to convince us to eat
them
this headline on wired.com is typical it
says the cicadas are coming let's eat
them
why not embrace brood x as the
free-range sustainable source of protein
that it truly is popular sciences
headline says
the brood x cicadas are coming and we
should and you should eat them here's
how
and the new york post says eating trendy
brewed x cicadas
what the bug recipes taste like now i'm
not sure how the cicadas themselves are
trendy
i've never really thought of bugs in
that way
but if you're wondering what these
recipes are well wjz
in baltimore had a report a few days ago
featuring a johns hopkins doctor giving
some tips on how to prepare
your cicada snack so uh so here's that
all right cicadas look soon gonna be
buzzing around everywhere in our area
it's gonna be fun
this was inevitable one expert at johns
hopkins says they make
cicadas that is for a very tasty and
eco-friendly meal stetson miller has
this for us
cicadas will soon be crawling all over
maryland
trillions of them in our backyards and
trees believe it or not that means
a lot of opportunities to try out a new
snack according to one johns hopkins
professor
they're a lot like shrimp they're like
tree shrimp sustainable food expert
jessica fonzo is planning to collect
and eat cicadas herself and wants you to
know that they're a great source of
protein
and also great for the environment we're
in the middle of climate change
insects there are a great alternative
source to
other animal source foods which for
example cows which are producing a lot
of greenhouse gas emissions
if you're brave enough to try one she
says you should pick out the nymphs
while they're still white
the ones that have just come out of the
ground and only eat the females
you can then freeze them in a bag and
when you're ready to eat boil them first
for two minutes
and then cook them to your liking you
can roast them in the oven
put some salt and pepper on there some
some
old bay seasoning on them
there's even a free cookbook online
dedicated to cicada dishes called
cicadalicious professor fonzo is urging
people to give them a try as an
alternative
green source of food it only comes
around once every 17 years
now first of all i have to say
claiming that they taste like shrimp is
not a selling point to me shrimp are
hideous foul tasting tiny little mutant
beasts themselves
they live in the they live in the dark
depths of the ocean ten thousand feet
under water
they're so they're tiny and gross and
ugly and god put them in the ocean deep
down
basically a bright neon sign from heaven
saying don't eat this crap and yet we
didn't catch the hint
we still scooped them up shovel them
into our fat faces so cicadas are like
shrimp not helping your case if true
but it's not true bugs don't taste like
shrimp
they taste like bugs i i've eaten some
bugs i've had crickets you can go to my
instagram right now
and see the video do you know what the
crickets tasted like
they tasted exactly like you think a
cricket would taste
there is no surprise the moment you eat
a bug
your immediate reaction is yep that's a
bug
and your second reaction is oh lord all
of its limbs are now stuck in my teeth
it's not a pleasant experience but it's
one that our cultural overlords
want us to have more often the push to
eat bugs has been going on for a while
now it's got big money behind us big
enough bill gates the bill gates
foundation has been promoting
bug harvesting for a long time though i
sincerely doubt that gates himself has
ever sat down to a bowl of
beetle soup the guardian had a lengthy
article a few days ago titled
if we want to save the planet the future
of food is insects
fried crickets on the school menu milk
made from fly larva
and meal worm bolognese for dinner these
are the environmentally friendly meals
we can look forward to
bon appetit milk made from
fly larva well that's only slightly more
grotesque than almond milk at least but
this is what the elites want for us the
un too has come out to promote bug
eating
overall the future they imagine for us
is one where we're living in our pod
home the size of a shipping container
eating cockroaches for breakfast and
wearing medical masks whenever we leave
the house
they want us all to live like um like
like we're like we're the last survivors
in a post-apocalyptic hellscape
basically
that's the ideal vision of the future in
their minds
and i find their vision repugnant
especially when it comes to the meal
plan
first of all it's it's not necessary to
eat bugs in order to save the planet
you're not gonna change the weather by
eating bugs i shouldn't have to say that
the claim being advanced by these people
and this is no straw man it's actually
what they believe
the claim is that if you eat crickets
for lunch enough times
there will be fewer hurricanes it's the
weirdest form of magical thinking
because as the logic goes cows
fart and burp a lot and that's helping
to cause weather-related catastrophes
and it's also melting the ice caps
so we have to look for a less flatulent
food source
but but not only is this ridiculous
not to mention a form of body shaming
towards the poor cows
but it's also it also ignores the
tastier solution
which is eat more cows and eat them
faster
so they have less time to fart second
we're told that bugs are a sustainable
resource
you know we don't have to worry about
running out they say that now anyway
we all know that once everyone starts
eating bugs it's only a matter of time
before they tell us that our bug
chomping ways
are causing a bug shortage and now we
have to start getting our nutrients by
eating
dirt popsicles and drinking smoothies
made from pond scum in our own urine or
something
but also more to the point even if bugs
are sustainable
so is our current diet we aren't running
out of food
there are people in this country and
certainly across the world who need food
but
that's that's a matter of distribution
not supply
it's similar to the idea that the world
is overpopulated and we're running out
of space
but that's not the case at all we have
plenty of space in fact
the entire population of the world could
fit inside the state of texas
if we wanted to the problem is in how
the space we have
is utilized we tend to crowd ourselves
like sardines into cities
while leaving huge swaths of land empty
so we're doing a pretty bad job of
using the space available that's the
point just as we may be doing a subpar
job in some cases
of using resources but but that's not
the same thing as running out
third most importantly has already
covered eating bugs is disgusting
it is beneath us as civilized people
we are too high on the food chain to
reduce ourselves to that
barbarity the push to make us eat bugs
is anti-human and it's degrading
there's a reason why we are viscerally
repulsed
by the thought of eating bugs or even
just the sight of bugs
they're dirty they're disease infested
they're gross
they are pests not cuisine you call an
exterminator when you have bugs in your
house you don't look up recipes
when your kid comes to you and tells you
there's a spider in his room you tell
him to bring you a shoe not the garlic
powder
in summary bugs are meant to be stomped
on and destroyed
not put into your mouth you sick freaks
and so eating bugs is cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated